when you talk about the people who are
so upset about it in Texas I think a lot
of the uh issue of who's upset about it
in Texas has to do with particular
political
orientation but does that matter yes it
does because there there are listen I'm
not arguing about whether or not too
many people are coming in but I do think
a lot of the hysteria even before even a
year ago before it was as as many
numbers as it is there was a lot of
anti-immigrant fervor that was based not
on a realistic appraisal of what heard
what was occurring but rather on on on
on racism and anti-immigrant uh uh
perspective you know Ronald Reagan gave
six million immigrants amnesty when I
was growing up if you wanted to come
into this country uh if you wanted to be
a citizen all you had to do is walk down
to the to the registry office